hello Brandon welcome back to Saint
Louis it's nice to see you here thank
you yeah uh what are you busy with these
days am I busy with these days yeah well
besides chess besides chess well I can't
really tell my competitors that but um
I I've been doing a bit of soul
searching
um I haven't been home for
more than
you know a week at a time since what
February so I've been traveling quite a
bit and you know just exploring and
enjoying myself so it's been nice to
take a bit of the pressure off my
normally pretty fast-paced life and sort
of relax a bit we have a lot of
tournaments usually you play a lot of
tournaments and I can see whenever I
open like any American Events or there
yeah and then how you How do you see
your future as like do you see it as a
chess player professional chess player
or do you want to do something else
which is connected to your degree yeah
it's kind of hard to say I mean for now
I'm sort of trying to go along with both
and see and see how things go but for
now I'm enjoying chess and and seeing
where it goes so why not continue with
that awesome and it's your last year in
this tournament what are your
expectations
yeah you know it's kind of funny like
when I was younger I thought okay well I
have maybe what three or four more
chances to play this program I'm sure
I'll win one eventually but now I'm in
my last year and you know all these
young kids are passing me so it's tough
being the oldest but I don't really
think I have any expectations anymore I
think I'm just trying to have fun with
it and enjoy my last year here perfect
are you looking forward to play young
kids oh these young kids you know
I don't think anybody would say yes to
that question maybe you would
no I think whenever somebody comes to
the board and they see their opponent as
you know less than half their height
so we really started having panic
attacks
so I'm pretty sure that's a pretty
Universal answer yeah okay and
um do you expect to win the tournament
in general I know you said you don't
have any expectations but let's say as a
goal is that your goal or just to gain
some rating points well I mean okay I
think I'll be lying if I said my goal
wasn't to win the tournament but yeah I
think it's kind of tough to think but
especially because everybody is so close
and level I think it's mostly will come
down to who's in the best form
um
so it's kind of hard to say and I think
like if I had to guess the winner of the
tournament will only be at like plus
three or something so it won't be a
crazy margin so I think
it's it's really anybody's game
perfect and good luck thank you and good
luck with the tournament
foreign